this is the philosophy of collectivism
the philosophy that says that human
beings suffer because the
judeo-christian system expects too much
of us individually judeo-christian
philosophy expects us to struggle to
strive judeo-christian philosophy
demands that we do our best and that we
act virtuously on the individual level
so that we can feel secure without
invading each other's rights the
judeo-christian tradition says that with
freedom comes responsibility
collectivist philosophy however thinks
differently they expect us to give our
individual striving up no more striving
no more struggle all we have to do is
trade our individual responsibility for
the comfort of collective power
collectivist philosophy points out that
individual virtue isn't natural it is a
struggle and we can avoid that struggle
by handing over all power to a nanny
state judeo-christianity says you're
free and therefore you must give
collectivist philosophy says your unfree
and thus the state must take on your
behalf